so at Jensen's were always looking to
discover new things and learn new skills
and I've always said cooking is
something every guy should know how to
do and what guy wouldn't want to learn
how to cook a steak today we're here at
the new school of cooking with Chef Ryan
luttrell and he's going to show us how
to make mistake with cognac peppercorn
sauce nice and brown on both sides now
it's time to make our sauce I show you
kind of how we do it at the new school
and let you take over from there I know
we're gonna add some cognac to it right
what is the cognac bring it really just
brings its own unique flavor I mean
there's there's nothing that can replace
the flavor of cognac right just panner
so well with peppercorns and the natural
flavors thank you so much for having me
yeah thanks for coming by I'm definitely
to cook this at my next get-together
yeah
show off some new skills
you can see these pieces from the 1940s
and 50s and it looks like a designer
jacket that was made distressed today
and you just see where they got their
inspiration from so I'm gonna take a
look around and check out a few pieces
and hopefully I could pick something up
Jensen started out of a passion for
learning new things you know we don't
consider ourselves the foremost experts
on all things gentlemen or what it means
to be a gentleman we go to places like
this and ask the denim experts here to
teach us you know where selvage comes
from or what the difference between
Japanese Salvage and Japanese twill is
and then we can share that with our
audience
you